you
welcome to Abbott's web series at Abbott
we know that a healthier Hospital begins
with a healthier laboratory because labs
performing at their best deliver results
that provide better patient outcomes and
improve healthcare value Abbott can help
you redefine performance with
personalized and innovative solutions we
hope you find Abbott's web series a key
resource in helping you achieve
measurably better healthcare performance
today's healthcare executives have many
issues weighing on their minds things
like reimbursement changes patient
satisfaction and population health
management just to name a few as a
result they have higher expectations for
all their departments including the
clinical laboratory in fact in a recent
global survey c-suite executives ranked
the laboratory as the second most
important department in delivering on
key performance indicators so what steps
should labs take to have a measurable
impact on operational excellence and
healthcare outcomes and how can labs
deliver maximum value to meet these
expectations hello I'm Jose Santiago
today we'll discuss how you and your lab
can continue to achieve operational
excellence and further contribute to
your healthcare institution with me
today is Paul Clarke who will discuss
the concept of the labs value hi Jose
glad to be here also with me is Patrick
gontar who will discuss the key factors
that drive cost and how they can
contribute to the underlying value of
the lab hi Jose happy to join you today
Paul let's start by talking about
realizing the labs value through
operational excellence two concepts
total value of ownership or TVO and
total cost of ownership or TCO these are
commonly used in other industries to
evaluate operational performance discuss
concepts are now making headway into the
laboratory setting
that's correct Jose in general value is
a difficult concept to quantify both
inside and outside the lab one way to
think about value is as an equation
which defines as the best possible
outcomes achieved at the lowest cost
today it's no longer enough for the lab
to simply deliver timely test results to
physicians just like the hospital health
system the lab must also demonstrate his
ability to contribute to positive
patient outcomes at the lowest possible
cost a UK study found that seventy to
eighty percent of all healthcare
decisions affecting diagnosis or
treatment are influenced by laboratory
results and while lab service is
typically made up between three and five
percent of a hospital's budget
the lab directly impacts 70% of
value-based performance areas and that's
that's a huge disconnect the critical
factors which affect how a hospital's
values measured are outcomes patient
experience efficiency safety and
clinical processes when the lab is
delivering to its full potential it can
help improve outcomes system-wide
allowing the institution to positively
impact their patients and the community
at large that's why it's extremely
important to avoid marginalizing the lab
we need to find ways to integrate the
lab more tightly into the overall
umbrella of healthcare decision making
and that essentially is how you change
the healthcare value equation in your
favor
it's also why I'll be talking about the
TVO methodology today and that's as a
way to ensure the lab is operating in
the most efficient way possible yes I
agree it's not always easy for
laboratorians to demonstrate their value
to the broader healthcare system but if
they truly could assess and communicate
their value they would be better
prepared to deliver on the high
expectations of the healthcare
management so let's discuss how labs can
go about assessing and communicating
their value using the TVO methodology
sure ensure TVO focuses on maximizing
operational efficiency taken into
account factors that go beyond the
direct and indirect costs of running a
system or instrument and the benefits
they produce as an example one factor is
space which is a precious commodity
regardless of where you are in the world
when a laboratory can optimize how it
uses its space it becomes possible to
bring additional testing in-house and
add needed instrumentation ultimately
something that may seem simple like
maximizing the use of space in your lab
to add a new test capability could help
you improve clinical care and elevate
the value of the lab to the healthcare
organization by conducting a TVO
assessment laboratories can find ways to
improve operational productivity and
efficiency and they can lead to
downstream clinical care benefits thanks
Paul we now better understand how TVO
helps uncover the true value of the lab
helping it to stay viable in the face of
rising costs budget cuts and pressures
to deliver more value to the overall
healthcare ecosystem so now let's turn
our attention to TCO or total cost of
ownership Patrick you've done a lot of
work in this area
can you help explain the concept of TCO
and how it differs from TV oh sure
total cost of ownership as it name
implies has to do with costs it is an
estimate and a calculation of all direct
costs for things like instruments and
reagents indirect costs such as employee
time energy water consumption
all of these contributes to the cost of
acquiring and operating an instrument
throughout its lifetime think about it
this way you can choose to invest in a
product that appears to be the most cost
effective option for an initial
investment perspective but if you
consider other elements such as how much
time it takes to maintain it you quickly
realize that the product may not be the
best option when you factor in all the
value of your extra time I completely
agree Patrick I'd add that we can
visualize TCO as a step towards TVO and
understanding a laboratory is overall
value TVO builds on TCO and complements
it with Lean Six Sigma processes to help
labs find a way to streamline their
operations and achieve the best outcomes
for their entire healthcare system in
other words TVO is more holistic because
it considers the additional benefits of
an investment or process and not just
costs alone furthermore TVO is all about
determining which decision will drive
the greatest value both from monetary
perspective as well as from a desire to
outcomes perspective so how can
assessing TVO help clinical laboratories
realize their value where we can look at
it in four key areas let's consider the
previous example where laboratory space
is one factor that can be modified to
improve the value of a lab first imagine
if a laboratory could do the same number
of tests in a smaller footprint or
rearrange the lab layout to bring in a
new test system that meets a particular
needs of the healthcare institution
think about the benefits this could have
a laboratory could be more nimble
bringing tests in-house that were
previously out sourced all by simply
reconsidering the labs physical space
secondly imagine if a lab found a way to
better use technician time rather than
performing mundane tasks such as
instrument maintenance technicians would
be able to provide more value added
benefits like improving the lab service
levels this could then bring additional
benefits to the broader healthcare
organization and you're doing all of
this just by looking at one factor
technician time thirdly improving
operational efficiency and effectiveness
not only helps save on costs it also
helps laboratories focus on the most
important aspects of care such as
increasing clinician and patient
satisfaction and then finally if a lab
gains more time to make data-driven
decisions it can ultimately help improve
patient outcomes and demonstrate is
value to the overall healthcare
organization I agree Pollan this is a
critical point going back to that global
study we mentioned previously 93 percent
of healthcare c-suite executives believe
the lab has a strong ability to impact
the management of healthcare analytics
imagine what could be accomplished if
there's extra time to really focus on
this exactly with more time the lab
could have more impact and be viewed as
indispensable to the healthcare
institution this discussion has been
great I wonder if you could share a
real-world example of a TVO based
analysis that Abbott has done sure we've
got many success stories worldwide but
I'd like to talk to you about something
I worked on recently we worked with
Korea clinical laboratory or KCl and
they are a research orientated Medical
Foundation and clinical lab and they
support several hospitals right
throughout South Korea and they offer
testing across a broad range of services
KCl chose to partner with Abbott
because they understand that the TVO
approach strengthens the quality and
measurement capability of their lab and
the head of KCl mr. kim seung-ho
recognized that total expenditures
include not only the one-time purchase
costs and reagent spend
also the overall operating cost of the
laboratory knowing that these additional
costs account for 85% of the total cost
of operating the lab he knew that the
only way to gain managerial efficiency
was to look at the other factors that
feed into the labs overall value Abbot
was brought in together with our partner
Patrick gontar who's who's obviously
here with us today
to use a TVO approach and find ways to
improve operational efficiency the goal
was to positively impact quality patient
care and demonstrate the true value of
the clinical lab the team completed a
three-day TVO workshop during which we
identified 45 areas of potential
improvement to complete both the TVO
assessment and the scoring tool Patrick
perhaps you can speak a little bit more
about the details sure through this
process
KCl realized that an inefficient
laboratory poses risks to the rest of
the healthcare system such as time and
efforts to remobilize staffed and
collects extra fluid sample to rerun a
test not only does this impact patient
care but it also effects an organization
financial performance and costs in terms
of tactical execution once we gather
baseline metrics and calculated the
potential impact of specific operational
inefficiencies we developed set action
items aimed at improving the processes
in the lab that we're adding additional
and necessary expenditures or
complications right
we then established performance metrics
that were monitored and reported to
senior leadership these TVO driven
initiatives led to some impressive
improvements in several areas such as a
22 percent improvement in earnings and
there are several factors that helped
kcl accomplish the 22 percent nominal
growth including labor savings quality
workflow and competency improvements as
well as sales and marketing initiatives
under a traditional purchasing model
none of these factors were considered
when going to tender and selecting a
Diagnostics partner
this is a powerful story it really
showcases the benefits of a TVO based
approach on improving operational
efficiency and demonstrating the lab's
value to the overall healthcare
organization not only was there
financial benefit there was operational
benefit and improved efficiency in
delivering diagnostic services and most
importantly a clinical benefit to the
patients whose experience was improved
through quality results and a quicker
triage through the system yes exactly
the TVO analysis revealed specific areas
that could be optimized at kacl to
realize the full value of the laboratory
to the healthcare system overall kcl
success and the process that was
followed is reproducible by any
laboratory TVO is just one of the levers
we use to help customers improve their
ability to provide greater value to the
customers and communities thank you Paul
this example was very helpful in
illustrating how the TVO methodology can
be applied to improve operational
efficiencies and demonstrate the true
value of the lab let's go back to the
concept of total cost of ownership and
there is no better person to speak about
this topic than Patrick Gunn tart
Patrick King can you tell me a little
bit about the benefits of focusing on
TCO and the laboratories you manage and
the clients you work with yes of course
as we heard earlier healthcare leaders
expect the laboratory be more involved
in improving patient management and
reducing the time to diagnosis an
intervention all while dealing with a
complex equation of competing priorities
cutting costs on one side while
increasing performance on the other side
a laboratorian must have previously
focused on cutting costs to help
positively impact his or her
organization's finances but my initial
question to clients is always the same
how are you currently assessing indirect
lab costs and their impact on the
broader healthcare organization many
labs don't know how to start this type
of analysis and that's when we come in
and assist them
you see healthcare organizations are
constantly looking for ways to cut costs
primarily due to the high upfront cost
of the analytic instruments
and the cost of the test themselves as a
result the lab often becomes a target
for downsizing or pure outsourcing I
completely agree with that Patrick and
that's why TCO is an incredibly
important part of TVO cost is part of
the overall value equation whether we
like it or not
so Patrick you are mainly focused on
helping laboratorians understand the
total cost of certain investments or
processes and helping them make
decisions that will minimize these costs
while maximizing operational
efficiencies you recently completed a
study that assesses the TCO of the newly
launched analytical system from Abbott
the illinit ECI series can you tell us
more about it
sure the reason I was interested in
doing this assessment was my first and
experience with the total cost of
ownership benefits delivered by the
Abbott instrumentation back in 2015 I
had performed a six-month study
comparing the Abbott architect to the
rush Kobus and I found that the Abbott
architect system was much more efficient
and less expensive in the long run as a
result of this initial TCO analysis I
was very interested in a similar
assessment of the new Allen et Cie
series as one of the latest instruments
to hit the clinical lab market as we've
heard laboratory managers might evaluate
the addition of a particular instrument
to their labs by only focusing on the
costs of the equipment itself and the
cost of reagents TCO takes an objective
and broader approach to understand all
the various factors that contribute to
the costs this includes the time
required to perform maintenance
utilities costs the turnaround time for
an assay and how easy it is to work with
an instrumentation and this is just to
name a few I know that you looked at
other platforms to evaluate the TCO how
did you ensure consistency and test
parameters across all instruments we use
the standardized study designed to
compare key characteristics that
contribute to TCO across five platforms
and four vendors namely Abbott Beckman
Coulter Roche and Siemens for
independent laboratories participated in
the study matched for size offering
analyzer configuration and test volumes
each laboratory run an identical set of
specimens and controls on their
platforms we run the same set of hundred
and sixty patient samples at each lab
with a mix of clinical chemistry
immunoassays and mix this panels and in
terms of overall assessment you focus on
three key operational efficiency drivers
correct yes
first we measured maintenance time which
include machine downtime due to routine
maintenance and human time basically the
time that the technologist spends on
maintaining the analyzer second we look
at turnaround time or ta T which we
define as the time needed to process a
sample including the average time to
process that tubes and finally we
compared electricity consumption by the
platform with regards to maintenance we
found that alline TCI outperformed all
the other platforms in terms of downtime
for maintenance we also broke out the
maintenance time by the number of hours
the instrument was unavailable and by
the numbers of hours staff members were
engaged in managing the instrument or
human time as you can see here the
eliminated CI series required 37 to 56
percent less annual maintenance time
than the other four platforms Patrick
these are great results this could lead
to considerable time savings for a lab
and could in turn positively impact
other KPIs in a healthcare institution
exactly instrument maintenance is
something we know is necessary to ensure
our tests are generated properly but
when you extrapolate the amount of time
needed to maintain a competitive
instrument in relation to illinit e you
could save let's say forty forty three
thousand dollars a year as an example or
if you think of that in terms of value
that could be a full-time technicians
job all year long 2080 hours per year
just doing maintenance that's
significant Wow so that is an entire
year of an employees time just doing
maintenance I can think of many more
productive things that a staff could do
to help increase the value of the lab
Patrick let's move to your second
outcome processing time across the
platforms yes we found that the illinit
TCI series
had the fastest peak performance it had
a throughput of a hundred and seventy
tubes in hundred and seven minutes which
is up to 39 percent faster than the
other platforms we tested what's
interesting is the Rosco bus 8000 shown
here by the maroon line you can see that
while it had the fastest processing time
up to the first hundred and thirty
samples the speed then plateaued in a
system saturation phenomenon what
exactly do you mean by the system
saturation phenomenon and and how does
it translate in terms of impact to
laboratory operations system saturation
occurs when the time required to run the
tubes is much slower than the scanning
time at some point the analyzers reaches
an overflow situation it can't run the
entire number of scan tubes which cause
a delay in analysis and reporting so you
just described an interesting throughput
phenomenon in a typical lab we know
throughput can be affected by multiple
variables for example when stat samples
are introduced into a routine it could
affect the stat turnaround time did you
consider this scenario in your study as
well as a matter of fact yes we
simulated the disruption caused by the
stat samples by placing 12 additional
samples on the instrument in random
order during routine test panels being
run we saw an average of 41 percent
lower stat processing time across
multiple analytes on the LNT and
architects systems compared to the other
platforms we know that tad can affect
many KPIs that extend outside of the lab
such as physician and patient
satisfaction or even Hospital length of
stay so it's important to be confident
in the real-world efficiency of the
systems you're using the third driver of
operational efficiency evaluated in your
study was electricity consumption
correct yes again correct in comparing
the five platforms about salinity CICS
system consumed up to 79 percent less
electricity than the other four
platforms
I'm glad you tested this Patrik because
it's not only important for
organizations that are cost conscious
but nowadays people are more more
concerned with their effect on the
environment organizations pride
themselves on being green running lean
being eco-friendly and environmentally
sustainable
this is an important finding I agree
Patrick what are the key takeaways from
the study that you like to end with the
primary finding was that Abbott salinity
sea ice series showed better performance
in three key operational efficiency
areas maintenance processing time and
utility consumption all of which
contributed to a lower TCO the Abbott
system also has the fastest stud sample
processing time of all comparators I'd
like to point out that this was the
first study to directly compare key TCO
components of the new alena t CI serie
to other platforms we did measure other
components of TCO including the time
needed for parts replacement for
calibration QC reagent loading water
consumption and ease of use and this
information will be published in a
separate report in the future and
laboratory managers will need to
consider these additional factors to
accurately compare TCO across analytic
platforms yes that is a very good point
Patrick thank you for sharing the
results of this TCO analysis your study
illustrates how important it is to
understand that different factors that
can affect the operations of the
clinical lab Paul based on everything
we've discussed today what would you say
to a lab manager who is looking to
actively contribute to improve the
overall value that his or her lab brings
to the healthcare organization I would
say that incorporating the concepts of
TVO & TCO into the daily work of the lab
while it can be initially challenging
yeah and requires a shift of the
organizational mindset beyond
considering direct cost alone the
benefits are enormous
I'd like to encourage labs to explore
the additional value that lies within
the laboratory walls and capitalizing
the benefits this can bring ultimately
TVO can help laboratories change how
they are perceived by the hospital
decision-makers and the impact they are
making on healthcare outcomes that
shifts them from a cost center to a
value center couldn't have said it
better I want to thank you both this has
been a great introduction to the
concepts of TVO & TCO I think we all
have a better understanding of how these
method Allah
can help lab managers achieve measurably
better healthcare performance and
demonstrate the true value of the
clinical lab in the institutions it's
been my pleasure Hosea thank you for
having me
I'd like to thank you all for joining us
today please feel free to submit any
questions you have to the address on the
screen you can learn more about using
TCO and TVO to uncover ways to improve
operational efficiency and communicate
the true value of your lab on the avid
core laboratory website at core
laboratory Abbott thank you thank you
for watching Abbott's web series we hope
you found it to be a key resource in
helping you learn how to achieve
measurably better healthcare performance
be sure to join us for the next Abbott
web series as you continue your quest to
transform your laboratory and
institution to be its healthiest
[Music]
you